i don't know about you
but among the basic elements in anime
wind is by
far my favorite right up there with ice
i think that there's really something
about this element that represents the
free spirit that resonates well with me
it also helps that i prefer sleek and
precise tactics in battle
over the sheer power of fire or the
sweeping might of water
being one of the stock elements in anime
there are undoubtedly a lot of
characters that could harness the power
of wind
fortunately anime truly shines in giving
creative twists to something seemingly
so basic but i won't be ranking these
characters according to who can blow
their enemies away the best doing so and
comparing power levels is an exercise in
futility
instead i'll be doing the top 10
characters i like be it due to their
story
how they affect the overall status quo
of the series how creative their
abilities are
or just how badass they are that being
said let's get started
[Music]
with the plethora of abilities and
powers available to the myhero academia
cast it was no surprise to find a
character who harnesses the power of
wind for my hero academia it comes in
the form of the boisterous innasa now
what surprised me here is the fact that
nasa doesn't look like your typical wind
user
he's big and burly and he doesn't look
like the typical sleek guy with wind
powers he's also not the brightest guy
around but don't let that fool you
though
he's one badass hero and that can be
seen in his being the ace of his school
and a fitting foil for todoroki a way
more hot-blooded one
up next is another shonen character jin
from yuyu hakusho
with yu yu hakusho seemingly getting
some much needed appreciation in recent
days i think it's just fitting that we
have jin on this list among the demons
in the series
jin's one of those that impressed me a
lot due to his energetic personality
he's the right kind of
upbeat and friendly enemy to yusuke in
contrast to the more sinister villains
and they match up pretty damn well he
makes very creative use of his powers
too the wins not only his weapon
but also his ally in helping him close
in on enemies is it me or does he remind
you of peter
pan too
at number eight is kagura
it didn't surprise me that one of
naraku's incarnations in inuyasha would
be someone with the power over wind
kagura fights using multiple variations
of wind attacks ranging from bullets to
huge tornadoes what surprised me more is
the amount of character development
kagura got
i think that among naraku's incarnations
gagura has become one of my favorite
simply because of the surprising depth
to her character
in fact she's the character you can
argue was forced into evil she doesn't
serve naraku out of her own will and has
some pretty neat scenes of her wanting
to break free there's also the
development with szechua maru to the
point that her legacy remains to haunt
the latter even after her part in the
story is done
next in seventh is kazuma from stigma of
the wind
[Music]
anyone remember stigma of the wind i
think it's quite an underrated show for
how much fun i had with it and with it
came for me one of the earlier
prototypes of the light novel hero
you know with that reserved appearance
that people often associate with kirito
clones and the status of being outcast
due to a floor somewhere but practically
overpowered everywhere else like datsuya
that's kazuma in a nutshell he can't
master fire magic so he went with the
next best thing
wind magic look where that bought him
standard wind attacks being able to use
his powers as a shield to the point of
being near invincible the list just goes
on i think that if you're the type to
like
overpowered and cool heroes this entry
just convinced you to watch some stigma
of the wind
in line is ren hakuway from maggie
ever since her introduction i always had
a liking for haku she provides the much
needed air of idealism and sensibility
in her family which at the point of the
anime was given the image of being the
leaders of some warmongering empire
conquering
civilizations left and right it doesn't
help that the best of the renn family
had introductions or eventually ended up
being on the darker and more
manipulative side of things
in contrast to especially the redhead
siblings harkaway provides a much softer
edge that doesn't mean that she's weak
though
she's the character that embodies inner
strength and resolve in contrast to the
more combatable princess of the
co-empire she also dons quite the call
and badass transformation when using the
full power of her gin
speaking of idealistic and innocent
fairy tales wendy marvels at number five
who could forget sweet little wendy
always bringing a vibrant energy to the
main fairy tale cast wendy's as tough as
wind users go she may not seem like it
at first but she's the wind dragon
slayer and we know what being a dragon
slayer means in this series sure she
mainly plays a support role compared to
the other dragon slayers but where would
the whole team be without her ever since
her introductory arc wendy has played a
very important part
in practically every arc both in helping
the team in battle
or keeping the combustible elements in
the guild in line with her bubbly
personality she can kick it up a notch
in battle 2 as well with access to the
powerful dragon force she can sure pack
a punch when needed to
comes in at number four
[Music]
with the crazy things we've seen from
jojo it seems ensuing that a win-based
ability would be lackluster however this
being jojo you just know that they'll be
able to pull out something creative out
of a mundane looking ability and on a
pillar man to boot in wamu's case his
entire body becomes his weapon as he
channels the power of the wind from his
signature divine sandstorm wamu's
capable of ripping
anyone to shreds by manifesting his
power in its most destructive form using
his very body
even people like caesar have trouble
against the power of warmu's attacks
compared to the wild abilities in the
jojo universe women's wind abilities may
seem tame by comparison but that doesn't
make those abilities any less dangerous
for both his unfortunate opponents
and himself
aston's childhood friend and eternal
rival finds himself on this list because
well why wouldn't he just like aster he
seeks to become wizard king
unlike aster though yuno is naturally
talented and can be quite condescending
with his amazing wind powers manifesting
in the form of arrows and blades
it's not hard to see why he wouldn't end
up that way for me yoona really shines
in his creativity in how he combines
multiple facets of magic to become a
resourceful fighter this
is in large part to self which i can
safely say has become his ace in the
hole in a lot of situations he's also
one of those people who you would think
of as an edgy anti-hero in his first
appearances but the story quickly turns
that around and shows him in a more
sympathetic light he's one of the more
unambiguously heroic guys out there and
i think that's a pretty nice change of
pace from the sasuke characters in these
shows
just falling a bit short of the top spot
on the list is the very badass
monkey d dragon
[Music]
man
the name monkey dragon is something that
all to send chills down the spine of any
pirate hot shot in the world of one
piece and for good reason too being the
leader of the revolutionaries is one
thing but having the title of the
world's most wanted man is another
especially when we have monstrosities
like kaido
and big mom in the one-piece world look
i know bounties and titles may not mean
much when it comes to the overall
strength of the characters in one piece
but it does still say a lot about him
don't you think this is why
every scene where he appears in and
directly intervenes is treated like such
a big thing such as the one where he
saves luffy from smoker i doubt that
anyone would be collecting the sky-high
bounty for dragon anytime soon i think
that he falls short from first place
because despite how badass dragon is he
doesn't quite have the amount of
development like our winner on this list
does
climbing the top and overcoming all the
competitors on the list we have
naruto
overcoming adversities one of the
greatest legacies naruto has carved out
for himself i'm not sure if naruto is
the first thing that goes into your mind
when we think of wind powers
but i think that few can match him in
terms of the trials and challenges he's
had to go through to get to the top
i think that that also has something to
do with the status of him being the main
character of a story that spawned over a
decade
and captured the hearts of many anime
fans still it's a real joy to see the
journey that naruto took which includes
the acquisition of his now iconic rasan
gun
overall i think that naruto deserves
this spot for being the quintessential
shonen hero for a lot of growing teens
in the early 2000s
he inspired a lot of growing kids in
those days and i think that this is the
greatest power an
anime character can have
so what do you think of that list how
would you rank these characters
tell me through the comment section
below because i want to know your
opinions on this
i'm sure you can also hit me up with
some awesome wind users in anime that
didn't quite make it to this list
that's it for this list stay strong stay
awesome and i hope to see you again
[Music]
you